>From this previous lessons and
courses what you really learned is
the big picture of machine learning.
You learned that machine
learning always starts with data.
It's not like a traditional program
where you build the decision making
directly into the code.
But with machine learning we always
start with a big amount of incoming data
and then it produces some decisions,
some ideas,
some summaries about that data.
So in this nano degree program,
we also need to start with the data.
In this first unit on model building and
validation,
we're going to talk about how it can
take in a big quantity of incoming data,
process it and
read some conclusions about it.